John Wintle safe enough acted alone this
is team dzs Turtle Beach not the most
fearsome of titles but that's because
they're named after the sponsor a
computer hardware company which pays
these guys to play halo xboxes
blockbuster first-person shooter and I'm
hey the boys are here at Gamescom in
cologne germany where over 350,000
gamers are expected to stream through
the doors over the next couple of days
they're playing for 10,000 euros in
prize money but that's the tip of the
iceberg throughout my career there was
there was a few hundreds of thousands of
dollars at our team could win throughout
the years but now we're seeing massive
high school you can actually become you
know a millionaire playing these games
now Andy is an ex professional gamer he
now works on Microsoft you might not
recognize him but around here he's a bit
of a celebrity one Spanish fan couldn't
help but ask for an autograph and get me
drunk together eSports or electronic
sports a big business over 10,000 people
packed into Seattle's key arena to watch
a games tournament in July the winner
went home with just over five million
dollars team turtle beach dream of that
sort of money they'll have to keep
playing for another two days if they
want to claim the cash but before you
think of quitting the day job most
players never see the big bucks only a
handful of gamers will pull in over a
hundred thousand a year but with
audiences matching traditional sports
gaming's now mainstream and the sponsors
are taking notice if team turtle beach
do well they'll be hoping their next
sponsor and name will be a big brand
Angus Bennett Bloomberg Cologne Germany